Washington debates for the seventies a
series of debates designed to bring
together for an open exchange of views
and opinions outstanding authorities on
vital issues facing the world of the 70s
[Music]
the topic Social Security Universal or
selected now here is Peter Hackett in
our society people are living longer
than ever before retirement comes
earlier than ever before hence our
senior citizens are finding many more
years to be lived without the financial
security of a job thus an issue of prime
importance to millions of Americans is
Social Security despite the fact that
Social Security is a fact of American
life and has been for many years since
its inception in the depression of the
1930s the system has been criticized for
some shortcomings some attacked the very
concept of Social Security and insist
that it be done away with welcome to
another in a series of rational debate
seminars presented by the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research a nonprofit nonpartisan
research and educational organization
our two debaters are Wilbur Cohen the
former Secretary of Health Education and
Welfare in the Johnson administration
and the noted economist dr. Milton
Friedman we also have with us a panel of
experts in the field people engaged in
making public policy through teaching
influencing and writing about economic
matters they will comment upon and
question our debaters now to present our
discussion Peter lizard or a longtime
Washington newsman who is Washington
bureau chief for the Chicago Daily News
mr. ELISA gore
ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
in a series of rational debate seminars
one would have thought that Social
Security was a program universally
accepted by most Americans and quite
beyond the reach of even a rational
debate not so of course and especially
not so when you have two of the
liveliest minds in the country debating
its virtues and its drawbacks this is
the sixth rational debate seminar of the
1970-71 academic year our subject is
Social Security Universal or selective
and our two participants are in the
order in which they will debate on my
right Wilbur J Cohen he's a former
Secretary of Health Education and
Welfare he's now Dean of the School of
Education and professor of education at
the University of Michigan mr. Cohen
became involved in Social Security
affairs before the inception of the
program in 1934 he was research
assistant to the executive director of
President Roosevelt's Cabinet Committee
on Economic Security the committee that
drafted the original Social Security Act
mr. Cohen is author of several books and
numerous articles in the field of Social
Security health welfare and education
and on my last and don't take this
literally
Milton Friedman one of the most noted
economists in the world today he is the
leader of the so-called Chicago School
of Economics known to some as the Cook
County School of Economics
he's been professor of economics at
University of Chicago since 1948 and is
currently the Paul Snowden Russell
Distinguished Service professor of
economics there he is the regular
columnist for Newsweek magazine and a
prolific writer having authored several
books on economics ladies and gentlemen
first mr. Cohan I am indeed gratified
that we have this opportunity for a
periodic reappraisal of the Social
Security system there was such a
reappraisal in the 1936 campaign when
President Landon attacked the Social
Security program is being a cruel hoax
the re-election of President Roosevelt
established for all time that the people
of this country believed in his
principles and it was extended in 1953
the program was again reappraised by a
Republican administration under
President Eisenhower and in 1954 it was
agreed that the program was sound and
desirable in the American system and it
was again extended in 1969 it was
reappraised again by President Nixon and
his cabinet officers and it was found to
be a kind of programs that should be
extended so I believe this fourth
reappraisal will be good and the net
result will be another further extension
and improvement of Social Security which
Congress will adopt this year Social
Security is a program which works 26
million people draw benefits each month
80 million people contribute to it and
it is a program which seems to have the
overwhelming support of the 26 million
people who draw the pen of its and as
far as taxes are concerned as much
enthusiasm for the payment of those
taxes as anyone can find
it is of course the most important
guaranteed income program in the United
States it provides as far as possible in
this world of doubt and limitation a
guaranteed income to the people who are
under it by providing for a mechanism of
insurance a trust fund and kinds of
taxes which enable the body politic to
believe sincerely and the political
people to believe that they have done as
best they can in this rather fallible
world of ours to provide a guarantee to
the beneficiaries who will receive it in
addition it is the biggest anti-poverty
program in the United States among the
26 million beneficiaries there are 11
million whom if there were no Social
Security would now be in the poverty
program it is a program which of course
by demonstration appeals to all of the
various income and other groups in our
society it appeals to the low income
groups because it does provide income to
low-income people and as I have
indicated many millions are kept out of
poverty by its provision its particular
value is that it appeals to the
middle-income group which is very
largely responsible for most of the
things that happen in the United States
in the political field while at the same
time receiving some support even
enthusiastic support from high-income
people very few programs in the United
States can say just exactly what I have
said that it enjoys the support of all
income classes very substantially but in
addition it enjoys a support of blacks
and other minority groups in our country
who believe that the payment of benefits
as a matter of statutory right without a
means test is one of the best
protections to them against
discrimination and variation in benefits
which comes from attempting to make the
payments the
termined by either states or localities
or income or some other item that does
not give them the degree of security or
assurance which the present program does
if success in my opinion is because it
has in it the principles that reinforce
the capitalistic free enterprise system
since it emphasizes thrift and saving
since it provides for individual
responsibility in making the individual
employee and his employer contribute for
it and because it's variable benefits in
relation to wages reinforces that
element in our free enterprise system
which varies wages and varies rewards in
relation to your contribution to the
system as expressed by the wage and
salary system therefore those who
propose to change it must in my opinion
demonstrate that they have a better
system that will reinforce our free
enterprise system that will win the
support of those who pay the taxes and
that they will win the support of those
who believe that this system does to
give them a measure of security it's in
the basic element in the Social Security
system of course is that it does not
have a means test a resource test or a
income related test of any kind that is
related to the point where you have to
show your income or your resources that
is of course what is most meaningful to
the poor and the middle class and the
minority groups and any substitution for
the present system which would provide
an income related test in instead will
of course
meet serious objections from the
American public and therefore would have
to be carefully substantiated before a
change could be made I would add only
this the Social Security system is not
simply an economic institution man does
not live by bread alone nor
are all of the elements of an
institution solely determined by
economists in the Social Security system
is a mixture a rare mixture of political
sagacity of economics of compassion of
understanding of institutionalizing in
our political system certain rights and
responsibilities of income provided to
people at the same time tying closely a
relationship to paying the cost that is
a very very important element in the
system and one which cannot simply be
analysed strictly on the basis of income
and outgo by economists political
figures sociologists those interested in
other aspects of our society having
rolled to play I am very happy that the
Chicago School of Millicent Douglas
before 1932 played a big role in
creating this system and along with
those from Wisconsin and Princeton they
provided the basic fabric of what is one
of the most remarkable and successful
programs that we have had in the United
States it course can be improved and it
should be improved in addition of course
we must find a better way to be able to
deal with the problems of poverty and
the problems of income distribution in
our country I have long publicly stated
that I favor a welfare system a welfare
reform an income payment program which
is administered solely by the federal
government which is administered and
financed by the federal government out
of general revenues but that system
should not be a substitute for social
security it should be a transitional
system as best we can make it which
would enable us along with other
measures in the field of education in
the fields of jobs in the fields of
public service employment and many other
types of programs to reduce the extent
of poverty but to make a social security
system a benefit payable
as a matter of statutory right the basic
system and to have those improvements
over time made which will enable us both
to eliminate poverty but at the same
time to have a program as Social
Security does which reinforces thrift
which reinforces initiative which
reinforces the program of rewards in
relation to productivity and I believe
that it provides a sound basis for the
improvements for the future Thank You
mr. Cohen astonishingly mr. Cohen stayed
within his allotted times I wasn't aware
that there was a Chicago School before
Milton Friedman but now we know there
was so I give you Milton Friedman
if I seem a bit confused as I talk to
you it's because I'm trying to figure
out where I am literally I ended up to
the left of mr. Lissa Gore which is no
mean feat and to the right of Alfred
Landsman which is no mean feat Wilbur
Cohen tells me I don't even belong in
Cook County so I will try to figure out
where I am but in the meantime let me
turn to the subject and my subject is
really two separate programs the Social
Security program of which Wilbur Cohen
spoke and also the welfare program of
which he spoke these two programs were
both introduced in the Great Depression
supposedly the first as a permanent
program to enable people to have
benefits as a matter of right and the
second the public assistance program is
a temporary program for people in
distress
like most government programs of course
both are still with us and larger than
they ever were I want to talk first a
little bit about Social Security then
about welfare and then try to put the
two together the great problem as I said
in discussing Social Security and for
simplicity I am restricting my comments
to old-age and survivors insurance the
great problem in discussing that program
is to separate rhetoric from reality mr.
Cohen gave you the rhetoric so I will
try to give you the reality the rhetoric
is that the Social Security program is
an insurance program in which
individuals have benefits as a matter of
right
they sure to them by the accumulation of
a trust fund this is pure rhetoric the
reality is that any relationship between
Social Security and private insurance in
which individual benefits individual
payments by individual benefits is
purely coincidental the benefits that an
individual may receive may vary widely
even though he pays the
amount of taxes as somebody else the
taxes people pay very enormous ly widely
even though they received the same
benefits in fact the benefits which are
related to earnings vary over a range of
three or four to one the taxes that
people may pay to acquire those vary
over a range of something like eighty to
one millions of people who pay taxes
will never receive any benefits because
they haven't attributable to those taxes
because they haven't paid for long
enough or because they receive benefits
as spouse instead of in their own right
the reality is that any assurance people
have of benefits does not derive from a
trust fund there is a trust fund it's
roughly of a little over thirteen thirty
and thirty five billion dollars some ten
years ago mr. Myers who is here from the
Social Security board estimated that it
would take a three hundred billion
dollar trust fund to meet the
obligations then outstanding today that
figure would be vastly higher the truth
is that if you strip the rhetoric from
the reality the truth is then what you
have is a system under which there's a
tax on the one hand and there are
benefits on the other the taxes that you
and I pay are being used to pay benefits
to the people who today are receiving
their their pensions that may be a good
thing it may be a bad thing but it is a
very different thing from individual
benefits actually related to individual
payments what assurance do people have
that they will get their benefits in the
future the reality is that the only
assurance they have is confidence that
future taxpayers will validate the
promises that present taxpayers are
making you and I are promising ourselves
benefits the assurance that they will be
paid is that future taxpayers our
children will in their turn impose taxes
on themselves sufficient to pay those
benefits that may be a sufficient
assurance but it's a very different
thing
from a trauma trust I think the right
way to look at social security is as a
tax on the one hand and a benefit
structure on the other and they're the
thing that has impressed me over and
over again is that I know hardly anybody
who will defend the tax system by itself
who will defend a regressive tax a
payroll tax on income up to a maximum i
know hardly anybody who will defend the
benefit system by itself who will defend
a benefit system in which some people in
great need get nothing other people who
have high incomes get the maximum amount
that the system owners and there are
many more detailed virgins and yet when
you put the two together the two
together have become a sacred cow then
mr. Wilbur Colin quite properly
described as widely approved and widely
back I think this is one of the most
extraordinary cases of imaginative back
packaging that the commercial world has
ever seen now let me turn for a moment
to the welfare system oh I want to go
back and say one more thing if you look
at the combined tax and benefit system I
believe there is little doubt that on
balance it provides benefits to people
in higher income classes than on the
average the people who pay the tax
that's not true in every individual case
but if you examine the system as I've
tried to in my fuller paper as it would
operate on a full basis I believe there
is a strong presumption that the old-age
and survivors insurance system transfers
income from low-income groups to middle
and upper income group now I want to
turn to welfare the welfare system I can
treat more readily because we all agree
it's a mess it's a system which is
highly inequitable it's a system which
has reduced incentives to work it is a
system which has demeaned many people by
separating people into two classes
welfare recipients and others and
inducing welfare recipients to remain in
that category on a permanent basis I
think that system is should be reformed
in the direction in which it should be
reformed as a direct
which President Nixon has proposed in
the Family Assistance Plan a negative
income tax although I don't agree with
the particular structure of that plan it
doesn't provide enough incentive now
what shall we do about these two
programs taken together in my view we
should not have two separate programs in
my view the government has no business
doing for people what people can do for
themselves individual separately are
perfectly capable of providing for their
own return what I would like my
government to do what I would like to do
as a taxpayer in my government is to
contribute to a program which assures
people in dire distress of a minimum
assistance to keep them from destitution
regardless of why they are destitute
whether they are old whether they are
unemployed whether they are disabled
whatever may be the reason why they are
destitute I would like to us to have a
single program which would provide
assistance and a minimum scale to enable
them to avoid the destitution and
therefore I believe that the right road
for the future is to unlined Social
Security meet every promise we have so
far made we have made promises and
commitments and we should fulfill every
one but unlined Social Security on the
one hand and on the other reform our
welfare program in such a way that it
will provide assistance to all who need
it regardless of the reason for their
need the details of how to do that I
have tried to spell out a little in the
larger paper that has been available to
you I cannot go into it here except to
say that on the Social Security side the
idea would be to provide people with
firm vested commitments for whatever
benefits they have so far earned under
the Social Security program and then
eliminate the payroll tax and eliminate
the further accumulation of rights on
the welfare side the idea would be to
have a full-fledged negative income tax
with a marginal
xr8 that would preserve a very large
measure of incentive I would hope a rate
of not more than 50% now let me end by
reading the final three paragraphs of
the paper I submitted because I believe
it puts in a nutshell what I want to say
Social Security programs involve annual
expenditures of over forty three billion
dollars these programs appear on
balanced to transfer income from
relatively low income classes to middle
and upper income classes they are
flourishing are widely regarded as
highly successful and seemed destined to
expand welfare programs involve annual
expenditures of fifteen billion dollars
these programs appear to unbalanced to
transfer income from middle and upper
income classes to lower income classes
they are in a state of crisis are widely
regarded as intolerable and seemed
destined to be transformed is this
another example of what George Stigler
has called Directors law in operation I
read you stigler's formulation of that
law public expenditures are made for the
primary benefit of the middle class and
financed with taxes that are borne in
considerable part by the poor and the
rich
[Music]
Thank You professor Friedman now mr.
Cohen will have five minutes for
rebuttal
professor Friedman makes a good point
that when you look at the Social
Security system alone is a tax or as a
benefit it probably would not be
justified separately but that does not
make the argument sound in saying that
when you look at them together they are
not sound my analogy would be a man
alone can be looked at alone a woman
alone can be looked at alone but when
you put them together something happens
that's what's happened in Social
Security putting them together has been
the art of doing something and it's more
than rhetoric professor Friedman also in
a sense of tax the concept of insurance
and that is mainly because he doesn't
know what the concept of insurance is he
defines it in a Friedman definition but
not the right definition insurance does
not mean that you have to have an
actuarial relationship between the
individual contributions and the
individual benefits if so all group
insurance says in the United States
would not be insurance under his test I
won't argue about his definition if he
wants to have his definition let him
have it it's not my definition it's not
the definition that the Congress of the
United States has given they've called
it some insurance the Supreme Court of
the United States has called it
insurance and my article in the
encyclopedia britannica calls it
insurance
[Music]
take your pick
[Music]
professor Friedman calls a lot of the
things that he doesn't like about social
security rhetoric and that's exactly my
point
my point is The Economist's of this
country do not determine all of the
choices and options and attitudes and
things that go on in this nation people
do live by rhetoric you couldn't
understand what goes on in the United
States if you didn't understand
something about rhetoric and think of
all the people in this audience that we
put out of a job if we didn't have such
a thing as rhetoric I believe in
rhetoric because it makes a lot of
things palatable that might be
unpalatable to economists finally
finally he attacks the idea to some
extent rightfully that the present
system is a system primarily of
redistribution of income to middle
income people I think he's actually
actually right and that is the political
sagacity in the Social Security system
since most of the people in the United
States are in the middle income middle
class system it is a program which
appeals to them now to the extent that
he makes a point that there is a
transfer of income from low-income
people to middle income that could
easily be rectified by certain changes
in the financing you don't have to do
away with the Social Security system to
rectify that but the reason why we owe
and all other types of programs that
don't appeal to the middle class don't
get appropriations don't get support
from the taxpayers is simply because
they do not appeal to the middle class
middle-income person true if you're an
economist you may exclude all matters of
politics but I would then say that's not
reality myth Milton and so I believe
that the essence of social security in
appealing to middle income is desirable
and those things that are criticized in
Social Security could easily be remedied
by certain changes now my major
objection to the negative income tax as
a complete substitute for Social
Security is that I am convinced in the
present situation the United States a
program
only deals with the poor will end up
being a poor program and there is every
evidence on my side that that is true
programs only for the poor since 1600
and one under the Elizabethan poor law
have been lousy no-good poor programs
and having a program that is only for
the poor not for the middle-income not
for the upper income is a program that
will not in a long time be financed and
supported by the American public and for
that reason I think one must try to find
a way to join these program I would
therefore argue that a continuation of
the Social Security system with some
support underneath of a guaranteed
income negative income tax welfare
reform national welfare system is more
in keeping with the American system of
free enterprise and with our political
system then dumping Social Security and
substituting for it therefore a poor
program only for poor people which in
the end would not give security to poor
people either Thank You mr. Cohen and
now for a five-minute rebuttal by
Professor Friedman as many of you
probably know there are quite a number
of state legislators that at one time or
another have passed a law saying that
the value of pi' should be three
according to myth according to mr.
Cohen's analysis of the meaning of
insurance that means that pi is now
three I recognize of course that
insurance does not mean that individual
payments are equal to individual
benefits but rather than individual
payments have an actuarial equivalent in
the benefits that are associated with
and there is no I assure you that in
that interpretation of insurance which
is the interpretation that is widely
accepted in youth there is very very
little connection between Social
Security as it is now set up in any kind
of an insurance program you can dream
now of course combining the taxes and
the benefits
serve a purpose it serves a political
purpose it serves a political purpose of
getting people to accept something under
false pretenses it serves a purpose of
selling to people a program which they
would not buy if they knew what they
were buying this is a political role of
linking them together and this is what I
meant when I said it was a triumph of
imaginative packaging but as an economic
matter as a political matter other than
getting an adopted the combining of the
two halves is not I am for I'm sorry to
say anything like the ineffable
chemistry of combining man and woman the
I am running a little puzzled by the
argument mr. Cohen makes here and in his
paper on the quay that that hinges
around the phrase a program for the poor
will be a full poor program that hinges
around the statement that he recognizes
that the Social Security program
provides disproportionate benefits to
middle classes but that's the price of
getting it enacted and what puzzles me
is this are we really helping poor
people by saying to him here is a
program under which we will take $2 from
you and give you $1 back and we can get
that program passed but we can't get a
program passed which will take a dollar
from you and give you a dollar bed well
if that's the case it seems to me that
that if I were one of those poor people
if I were one of the people who mr.
Cohen is talking to and saying don't
worry we'll take care of you we promise
that therefore every two dollars we take
from you you'll get one back I wouldn't
repeat Thoreau's wonderful comment and
when I hear that people are coming to do
me good I run as fast as I can to get
away from now I think fundamentally what
is it bottom of the difference between
mr. Cohen and May and here I agree with
them is not economics is not economic
analysis but its basic philosophy I
believe there is a fundamental
difference between two philosophies
one philosophy is out of a society in
which the ultimate entity is the
individual in which the society rests
upon the idea that people are
responsible for themselves and that
people are responsible for those close
to that if I have a moral responsibility
it is an individual responsibility then
I cannot discharge by paying taxes
levied on me by some Congress I have to
discharge it personally that's one view
that's my view I believe that mr.
Cohen's view one which unfortunately is
very widespread and very widely held is
different it treats the nation as not a
collection of individuals and of the
groups which individuals separately
value but as an organism akyuu 'not I
read from his paper says mr. Cohen I
speak for the view that the nation
should be generous toward the elderly I
would argue that the nation can't be
generous to anything only people can be
generous generosity is a human
individual tree not a collective trait
there's no generosity involved in my
imposing taxes on you to help him
that's not generosity and but
nonetheless underlying the social
security view and it is a view that is
very widespread is it
society is an organism that there is a
group within the society who knows
what's good for other people better than
they do themselves and that that a leech
has an obligation a duty and a
responsibility to induce the public at
large to pass the laws that will be good
for them that in particular it has the
obligation to package this program and a
way in which they will adopt it even if
they would not adopt each part
separately now obviously that's not the
way mr. Cohen would describe his
philosophy but he is an eloquent man and
describes it very well for himself but
it does seem to me that fundamentally at
bottom you do have these different views
and that he is right in saying that
there is a far more fundamental issue at
stake than the issue
the technical issues involved in the
detail of the program that fundamental
issue is as we look toward the future do
we want to see our society develop in a
way in which individuals separately will
have greater responsibilities or do we
want to see it develop in a way in which
the collective entity is more dominant
and more omnipresent speaking for myself
I would say that our growing wealth our
growing income makes it all the more
possible for us to let individuals
separately run their own lives and I
would like to see us develop in a way
which gives greater freedom to each one
of us separately and which reduces the
role of collective entities
[Applause]
there are cogent arguments as we've seen
on both sides of this issue of Social
Security Dean Cohen feels the Social
Security system is a sound one that its
shortcomings can be cured by changing
the present system rather than by
adopting a new one dr. Friedman to make
use of his own words wants to reform
welfare and unwind Social Security we go
now to our panel of experts for their
questions and for answers from our
speakers would you kindly identify
yourselves and direct your questions
that one or both of the speakers who has
the first question yes I've guarded
McCammon Senate Committee on Aging I
have a question for mr. Friedman with
his last estimate from Bob Meyers of 300
billion dollars deferred cost what
happens to the economy if the nation's
workers are faced with the collapse of a
system in which they believe how do they
get their 300 billion dollars out right
now what happens in the future to
provide any incentive for people to save
through private pensions are through
individual savings when whatever income
they managed to put by is going to be
make them ineligible for a needs test
they payment well you've asked a number
of questions together let me take them
one at a time first with respect to the
300 billion dollars we have that in
which probably is 500 billion or
something like that now we have that
obligation now the only question the
only point is that it is not funded it
is not written on paper no economic fact
has changed by funding it it's got to be
paid now somehow or other in the future
and what I'm proposing here is that we
recognize that we have that obligation
that we write it down on pieces of paper
that we funded in the form of an
explicit government debt instead of an
employee
one and then in the details which I have
in the paper I have funding it in a way
in which workers would get it ultimately
at the same time as they now would but I
want to enable us to discontinue further
regressive taxation of the workers now
the second so there will be no collapse
of the system that's just again a
figment of the imagination
the fact is you now have that debt you
now have that obligation if that's going
to collapse the system the system should
collapse now second the question of
incentive the facts are almost the
reverse of what you're speaking of our
present Social Security tax is a large
distant sentiment anybody who goes to
work over 10% of his wage cost at the
low levels up to seventy eight hundred
dollars now it will be higher later on
over ten percent of his wage cost to his
employer is now taken out and sent to
Social Security and he only gets less
than 90 percent of therefore he does not
have sufficient incentive now indeed one
of the great problems of providing
sufficient incentive for people to get
off welfare is that if they get off
welfare and take a job well then over
and above any reduction in their welfare
benefits they now have to start paying
Social Security taxes they have to pay
ten point eight percent of their wage
cost in taxes and that raises a marginal
rate the in fact I was astounded when I
went through these numbers I had always
thought the disincentive to work was
associated with a high tax rate of the
personal income tax I am now persuaded
that the Social Security tax is a
greater distance set of to work there
are the high rates of the personal
income tax because it hits people lower
down it hits people who have the
alternative of relief and it hits them
hard the Social Security tax paid on
behalf of people today is for most
people decidedly higher than their
personal income tax so in my belief in
my opinion eliminating the payroll tax
would add to incentives of people to
work it would give us a larger output it
would make it more feasible for people
to put their own funds aside to provide
for their
later benefits for their own private
pensions back common first I don't think
there's any really empirical evidence
that Preta that Friedman can support the
show that the payroll tax has been a
disincentive number two if Social
Security were abolished and left a
private enterprise then the union's
through collective bargaining would see
that the same tax would be put on
through collective bargaining so the net
economic effect that he's suggesting is
exactly the same if they didn't put it
on through collective bargaining it
would then have to be paid out of
general revenues in which the only way
you get the money is raising the
marginal rates back from 70% to 90% as
they were before now what I'd like to
know from Professor Friedman which of
those two does he recommend the union's
bargaining with the employers to put it
on through payroll taxes or raising the
marginal rates back to 90 percent
neither how're you gonna get how you
gonna get the money there well the money
for which for paying that debt we now
have no not at all for for giving people
the security which they would get
through the parents place there is an
enormous difference between individuals
separately paying over part of their
wage to buy a pension which they
separately desire that is not a
disincentive if I spend some of my
income to buy a pension out of my own
free will that's part of my payment that
is not a disincentive the disincentive
arises because the Social Security tax
which is deducted from my salary has a
very minor relation to any benefit which
I will subsequently get but what you're
living in an unreal world professor
Friedman you know that if the Social
Security were repealed it wouldn't be
left to individual John Jones the unions
would bargain with the employers to put
that cost right back on entirely on the
employer which would have exactly the
same economic effect as it has now you'd
have larger reserves than you had now so
what would you have gained economically
you'd have the same distance that is but
that is what your
saying is wrong it is wrong for several
reasons it is wrong first because only
25% of workers are today unionized and
most workers are not it is wrong in the
second place because the unions would
only bargain for such pension benefits
of this kind as the workers would prefer
their union members would prefer the
union leaders aren't after all the
employees the agents of their own
members they would only bargain for such
benefits as their own members would
prefer to have in the form of pensions
rather than in the form of cash in the
third place of course both under Social
Security and under union arrangements
there is no important difference between
whether in the first instance attack the
some is paid by the employer or the
employee may agree therefore the you
heal others would put this kilogram the
employer no I have to stop because this
is a historic moment mr. poet in every
single thing I have ever seen that he
and other people have written has denied
the proposition he just agreed to he
agreed now I have never heard it I have
never denied you've never seen or heard
where I've denied it I justify it not on
economics I support it on the basis of
aesthetic logic which you don't
recognize excuse excuse me I have seen
you right I have seen things written
under your name maybe you didn't write
them with your name was signed
I have think seeing things written under
your name in which you compared the
benefits received by an individual to
the tacit to the employee tax without
making mention of the employer tax and
implying that that employee attacks
could be neglected in relating
individual payments to individual
benefit Nelson what you have seen but
not correctly interpretive is the fact
that you use the employee contribution
as a measure of equity in the system but
you there is also such a thing as social
adequacy if you read Reinhart whole
houses the vice-president Metropolitan's
famous essay of 1937 on equity and
social adequacy in social insurance
you'll see that both elements are given
some weight I completely support the
idea that in social insurance you have
two attributes and equity concept and a
social concept that is the art that's
made Social Security a acceptable system
we are talking across purposes I want to
ask you a simpler question a very simple
question do you agree that the tax on
the employer that the division of the
total tax between the tax on the
employer and the tax on the employee has
little or no effect on who pays it that
is correct so what okay if that is cover
what you draw do man I draw it excuse me
I think I'll just go
well as I say I regard that as a
historic moment because I have never
seen in any social security document or
in any document written by you that
admission and that admission means that
many of the statements made by you and
by Social Security about the relation of
benefits to amounts paid or to put it -
not to put a fine word on it our pure
hogwash well you know there's an old
unit in his term called foot spa you and
I professor Friedman demonstrates what
suka puts Bob better than anyone else I
know when he disagrees with anything
that somebody has said he says you're
not meeting my definition well the point
is simply that the Social Security
system does meet these tests of
insurance meets a test of equity meets a
test of social adequacy and the fact
that he doesn't agree with it you know
he's not Congress he's not the American
people he's only an economist thank God
for small favors
should we try another question I've seen
or Circuit of North American newspaper
Alliance my question is directed to
Professor Friedman in your paper and in
your remarks you've stated that
public assistance was intended as a
temporary program for persons in
distress to be largely phased out as
employment improved into Social Security
matured and there's then you say there's
no sign that Social Security is
displaced assistance both are at
all-time highs at cetera now aren't you
mixing apples and oranges here professor
Friedman isn't it a fact that the
portion of the public assistance program
which is directed to the hazards at
which the Social Security program is
directed that is old age and orphan
premature death of the bread a death of
the breadwinner isn't it a fact that
those portions of the public assistance
roles have declined markedly and to that
extent the Social Security system has
accomplished what it set out to do the
Social Security system was not created
and nor has it ever been in business to
take care of family break up due to
divorce and desertion well I observe
those are the factors which have made
the public assistance roles leap to an
all-time high the there is no doubt that
some of the people who are being who are
receiving benefits under Social Security
are people who in the absence of Social
Security might be on the assistance
rolls that's quite right now the
question and I I wouldn't want to argue
for a moment that there isn't some
substitution or competition between the
two what I meant to say here is that in
this initial version a large partner
trying to find a phrase in mr. Cohen's
paper which said essentially the same
thing about the about the initial
content and the initial version the idea
was that the
[Music]
here we are said to mr. Cohen bottom of
page 10 the 1935 decision was to accept
plan 2 with the hope that the welfare
portion would ultimately wither away now
the initial idea was that old age or
unemployment the identifiable things
were the major source of need for public
assistance and that if those were
adequately taken care of the need for
public assistance would largely wither
away and disappear
and what I was trying all I was trying
to say here is that that has not been
achieved that on the contrary public
assistance has grown it might be that it
would have grown still more rapidly if
there'd been no Social Security system
but that's by no means obvious the
reason it's by no means obvious is
because while Social Security has while
there are some people now receiving
benefits under Social Security who would
be under public assistance there may
well be some people under public
assistance who would not have been there
if there had been no Social Security
program because you must look at the
taxes that were extracted from people as
well as the benefits they received now
up to now the persons who have retired
have received much more than they ever
paid separately as taxes that's the
difference between the young and the old
and so undoubtedly today more people are
displaced by Social Security than are
added to the public assistance role by
Social Security but it's not obvious
that's going to continue to be the case
you still have your question question
for mr. Cohen Phil Carlson House
Committee on government operations you
place considerable emphasis on the
public acceptance of the Social Security
system do you see this continuing after
the first enthusiastic recipients those
who I think probably got a better
bargain out of Social Security than
future recipients will get you see this
same public acceptance continuing I
believe that as the payroll taxes go up
there will be a greater degree of
resistance
against future increases beyond some
limit that people think is acceptable
and therefore I believe that you will
have to consider several alternatives
which I have written about in my public
papers and some of them may be as
follows
increasing the payroll tax on the
employers substantially above the
present limit providing for a
governmental subsidy perhaps reducing or
rebaiting the tax on low income people
and perhaps having some type of
guaranteed minimum or negative income
tax and building a double-decker system
in which you'd give X to everybody out
of general revenue somewhat like mr.
Friedman suggests plus a variable
benefit related to the contributions you
make there are a number of such
possibilities and in my paper I have
indicated that all of those are possible
as changes in the Social Security system
keeping the present general purpose and
general direction now I just want to ask
one question to mr. Cohen in this
connection he has been emphasizing the
extent to which you can project the past
into the future does he also project
that just as in the past 20 years the
tax per person has died has gone up
twice as fast as a benefit per person
that that will also continue because I
think that's very highly relevant to the
question that was just asked we've had
tax per covered person has risen seven
and a half fold from 50 to 70 and the
benefit paid has risen something like
threefold do you think that that
discrepancy will continue well I don't
know of course during the same time
marginal tax rates for people in higher
income groups have been reduced from
ninety percent to 70 percent maybe what
we have to do is increase that 70
percent to 80 or 90 under your proposals
for more general revenues you are
pushing for higher marginal rates on
higher income people that's what your
proposals are leading to I am what you
favor but that's what you're gonna get
it's not why I favor and it's not I hope
what I again and let me emphasize that
what you just stated about the income
tax is not correct because you are
looking at nominal rates and not at real
rates inflation has
raised the burden of the income tax so
that despite decreases in rates the
average effective rate paid on the
personal income tax is higher today than
at any time in our history including the
peak date in World War two freshening
the corner
I like to ask mr. Cohen please sir how
do you ascertain the assertion fact that
private initiative and private pension
funds are greater because of or in spite
of Social Security if I said that they
are growing how you know they wouldn't
have grown twice as fast if you hadn't
had Social Security they would have I
would agree they would have had to grow
twice as fast if there weren't so dirty
because the social need would have been
there I do not deny that it has been a
deterrent to the growth of private funds
well certainly it's been a deterrent
thank God because if you would have all
of this money in private pension plans
at the present time with no vesting and
with the sort of things you have in
present private plans and studebaker
companies going bankrupt leaving people
with our pension rights you'd have
disaster in the United States so I
believe that the blend of Social
Security which is a minimum guarantee
plus the selective private pension for
companies and unions and comported is
the best of both possible worlds
gentlemen we have time for one brief
question and hopefully a briefing the
hope springs eternal
[Music]
University professor Friedman you have
been preaching the gospel consumer
sovereignty and I just I am pulling a
gimmick with you but I'm just wondering
why this contrary to the gospel of
capitalism of freedom that when a
Christian that this consumer sovereignty
if individual that Seco xerath embodies
monetary history of the United States or
whatever where he wants to spend his
money but it is not consumer sovereignty
one day a number of individuals band
together and decide that they want to
have social security or some kind of
benefits paid by the government and for
which they want to contribute or for
which they are going to get at some
future date but do you have some special
knowledge that this is country to the
will of their electorate of the United
States well I think you've asked not a
simple question but an extremely
complicated question that goes to basic
political philosophy and the in the
first place I have not been in any way
saying that we should violate the laws
of the land or that the law should be
decided in another way I've been trying
to persuade the people if they ought to
vote differently
that's a trying to serve the same
function with respect to consumer
sovereignty as you define it as
advertising serves with respect to
consumer sovereignty in the in the
private market but much more
fundamentally I believe there is a
philosophical difference between
consumer sovereignty in which a hundred
percent of the people decide to join in
a program and a situation in which 51
percent of the people
impose taxes on the other 49 percent of
the people I don't believe they really
come under the same rubric and I think
you do not agree you do not believe so
either if I said to you under your
definition of consumer sovereignty if
51% of the people vote to shoot the
other 49 percent of the people is that
appropriate consumer sovereignty you
would say no of course not
the similarity well but exactly the same
way it is not an appropriate similarity
to individual consumer sovereignty a
minute to say the 51% of the people vote
to impose taxes on a hundred percent of
the people in order to pay benefits let
us say to one hundred percent of the
people I favor majority rule as an
expedient as a way in which there are
certain decisions have to be made
jointly and this is the least bad way of
doing it but I do not regard it as a
principle
whereas I do regard individual
responsibility for himself that my using
my resources to achieve my objective so
long as I don't interfere with anybody
else doing this length I regard that as
a principle the wholly different kind of
majority rule is an expedient mr. Cohen
a final common individual responsibility
may be defined as a responsibility of
people to have the freedom to starve if
they wish I believe that there's a
higher and more noble principle and that
is a social responsibility of all
society when is mr. Friedman says the
commandments say honor thy father and
mother
it did not say honor thy father and thy
mother as economists have predetermined
it said honor thy father and a mother in
all of the ways that you may think of
including social responsibility and that
is what social security is
[Music]
I want to thank both of you who I think
have shown us what debate means and also
what cooks pas means and I want to thank
you ladies and gentlemen for your active
participation
[Music]
not bring a end to the discussion of the
pros and cons of Social Security our
focus of course has been to bring forth
some pertinent views in this field the
American Enterprise Institute has been
pleased to present arguments on both
sides
this is Peter haggis in Washington
Washington debates to the 70s is created
and supplied to this station as a public
service by the American Enterprise
Institute Washington DC
[Music]
produced in the nation's capital by
broadcast News Washington
[Music]